how do I build and scale a website in
Google Cloud you seem like a really
smart person do you know anything about
scaling a website based on traffic when
a user sends a request to your website
clouddns translates the hostname to our
web server's IP address then the request
goes to Cloud CDN which responds from
Cache if it does not find anything in
Cache then the request goes to load
balancer which balances load across the
web servers whoa that's amazing what
about static files such as images well
static files are served from cloud
storage then the internal load balancer
sends the request to the app server and
eventually to a database for that you
use cloud armor how do I scale my web
and application servers when traffic is
growing well you deploy your application
and web server is on cloud run which is
serverless and scales as traffic grows
and if you're using compute engine then
you can use managed instance groups
which Auto scale as the load increases
now that's some rock solid information
Priyanka